name of of my album in spanish is kahe
serosinko this is
in english is kg 0516.
[Music]
this album means a lot to me i don't
know if it's going to be
number one in the charts i don't really
know but in my heart
it's like my number one in my heart is
like a
huge album
i already know that your fans are going
to eat it up i mean they love you so
much and
you've always been so open and shared so
much of your personal life
with your fans i wonder has that changed
at all
you know the the more music you put out
do you feel like you're becoming more
private maybe
and wanting to leave all those stories
in your music
yes of course you know what like uh one
of the most
like important things that i miss a lot
it's a little bit of privacy it's kind
of weird because when you start in
in this career like you really want the
people to know you
you know when i i used to dream i was
like i remember when i was
dreaming just saying how it's going to
be
possible like with a lot of people in
the world like
people just know one and see it in the
streets
and say like that's kind of g that that
was amazing for me but right now
i miss a lot of that part and
and yes like i just got 30 years
like two weeks ago yeah and i think i'm
like
i i feel myself like 12 or 15 years
because i
like it the time is passing and i enjoy
more like my family
and be it in like five places and
and by myself and i i really want to
keep things
for me to me like social media gets a
little bit toxic sometimes
and and i get scared sometimes because
you become
what people talk about you and you don't
have that right of that moment to
explain like you know you are not that
you are not what people are saying
sometimes there are a lot of fake news
and you don't know where they come from
and it's weird and it's hard and it's
frustrating so yes
you you when if you can't keep it
private i think it's it's it's better
and you know what that's reflected in
one of your songs on the album too
beautiful boy you said
i changed my plans i hardly go out i
rather be in my bedroom is that true do
you rather just stay home
oh my god that's me right now that's me
right now like i just like working so
hard because
you know we're doing the price of my
album but yes that
like it can be one of the lines the
important lines in in my album
it's like all my change plan all my
plans
change right now all my plans change i
think like everybody's plans
like this year this last year changed a
lot a lot
let's talk about your future plans what
does this next decade
of carol g look like what goals do you
have
oh my god i feel so old girl i'm 32. i'm
two years older than you
i know 30 years but believe me like i
can't
normal if i can say you like normal i
look like in my inside i look at like a
12 year old so
i'm just thinking about this like the
theories in my id
and just keep it like my style in in my
inside but i have a lot a lot of dreams
not just
in the music as a woman uh i really want
my family i want to have a family i want
to have kids
and as a business girl like i want to um
experiment new things in different ways
not just like the music
in business like we're we're working
this last year we have been in in
different meetings
to evolve in different ways so let's see
what's going to happen like i know i'm
30 i know i'm old
20 years old yeah explode this thing
are you kidding me we're going to be
seeing carol g for years and years and
years you're not done yet all right keep
dreaming
uh but you know knowing that you want to
be a mother one day what's it like to
see your friends like nicki minaj and
nothing natasha
be moms for the first time oh my god it
i don't know it
makes me feel like a little bit sad like
sad and happy
because you know what one of my dreams
when i was a child was to have a baby
like in my 20s
so i i couldn't do it and because of my
career it's like
kind of hard to have that time a special
time because i really want to have my
my time with my babies not to put people
to take care of them no
do it by myself and just go away to
of everything and just enjoy my family
but let's see what what the future like
brings to me i know i'm gonna be a good
mom an
old good mom a cool mom you're gonna be
a cool mom i could tell
mom yeah i'm gonna be a coma it's one of
my dreams
and and i see and i can see it right now
like
very close to me so i'm very happy for
them and i'm very happy for nikki and
i love i love babies i'm going to be
very
happy for mine yes well i want to help
you make
one of your dreams come true because
every time we talk to you you talk about
how your ultimate dream collaboration is
with rihanna
something that i would love to do is
perform
with rihanna please rihanna if you're
watching this
please yeah she has to be so tired about
sending these messages to her because
you know what like i
realized that not all the corral
all the collaboration has to happen so
with her
like i have it in my heart like i hope
one day to have that opportunity but for
me
it's most important is she knows
that a lot of things in my career and a
lot of things that i've done
in my life it's because of the
inspiration
that i get from her from her like
experiences in her life and
the thing that she does uh yeah so right
now i'm not going to tell you rihanna
riri
i want to collaborate with you because i
know you know uh
i just want to say like mommy you are
the best
really believe me this girl right here
admires you
so much do you think you'd ever put out
like a lingerie line or
a beauty line like she did with fenty
skin and savage xenti
and i'm going to put a lingering brown
lingerie brand because
i'm not going to compete with my girl
but and she's huge so there's no
way but uh yeah i have another plans
like that
like um as i told you before like as a
business
like i have things that i want to evolve
with with a brand of catalogy so i have
some surprises
in the way